Jobs are just disappearing.
Now let's ask the question.
Is there anything that could be done
about that?
Well,
your Western society is tried very hard
with a number of environmental
environmentally based interventions,
early childhood education.
By the way that you said the.
The literature in organizational
psychology is very clear.
The winter jury is equally clear in
educational psychology.
Oh yeah.
Well the relationship between Iq and
learning is more powerful than the
relationship between Iq job performance,
that that's right,
which is kind of common sense or matches
are common sense,
but you know,
if you put a bunch of variables into a
regression equation to predict academic
achievement and you have all these
variables and teacher quality variables
and cognitive variables of the students
and what you find is the teacher
variables and the quality of the school
variables to gather barely account for
10 percent and I know,
I know.
It's terrible.
It was terrible.
You know what I told?
He's the guy who ran admissions at
Harvard.
I taught at Harvard for a while.
His name was dean with law and he is a
really smart guy.
I really liked the,
and you know,
he was,
let's say he was on the right side of
the human race and he was really trying
to figure out how to run the admissions
policy at Harvard so that it did the
best for everyone concerned and he had
run an interesting series of analysis
that I don't believe he ever published.
And one of them was um,
well let's say you segregate the Harvard
population into the relatively low Iq
kids.
So maybe they only have an Iq of 130,
you know,
and the relatively high Iq kids who were
pushing up towards 160.
So you are two competing hypotheses.
Fair one would be that the lower Iq kids
come to Harvard,
this remarkable environment and they,
and they and they,
they thrive because of the high
educational quality so well that they
close the gap between them and the one
60 kids.
And that's just completely,
completely wrong.
What happens is you put both those
groups,
they're both very,
very highly selected,
but some,
you know,
in this,
in a sort of superman rage
intellectually.
And what happens is the gap just gets
bigger and bigger as they progress
through university.
And it's a dreaded example of that,
uh,
matthew principle that the economists
talk about,
which is no to those who have more will
be given.
And from those who have nothing,
everything will be taken.